hi everybody i just finished up a
phenomenal interview
with my friend frank wilczyk who is a
really
unbelievable unparalleled intellect in
my mind and
in many physicist minds but also in the
public's mind he does a tremendous
amount of
of engagement with the public in his new
book fundamentals
ten keys to reality is now out here's
the cover
here's the actual book is down here
don't worry i read the whole book
and i've done now two podcasts with him
about it
but this is my third podcast with him
total if you're keeping score at home
and we got into a great deal of his
insights into
really as he calls the book the nature
of reality and what it's predicated on
the foundations of the universe and its
comprehensibility
are really keys to understanding what
the limits of human intelligence are
what the potential augmentation of
artificial intelligence might mean for
humanity and
uh and also prospects for things that
transcend the laws of physics
uh such as religion uh alien life
and other things that you'll hear about
you'll also
hear about his his advice to his former
self
his answer to my famous monolith
question
and also his uh his his ethical will
which you won't want to miss he promised
me that last time we spoke about a
beautiful question
back in november and now he answered it
today
but you only hear that if you sign up
for my mailing list at bryankeating.com
i
i'm a little concerned about the powers
of
big tech and people are getting
rightfully concerned about
technology perhaps um you know
controlling
our access to to the fans and the
audience out there so i do want to
encourage you to sign up for my mailing
list at bryankeating.com you'll get
advice for life from not only from frank
but from
folks like jim simons and from even
uh people that uh you haven't heard
podcasts
from yet such as avi loeb who uh
recorded a podcast with me
uh just last week i also have julian
barber coming up on the podcast so
please subscribe like
and do all those things for this podcast
to keep it going but do subscribe to my
newsletter if you want to hear the
answers to the
thrilling three questions that i ask all
of my guests including frank wilceck
which is delayed back in november but
have no fear you will get those answers
right here
if you uh subscribe at brianketing.com
just go there takes a second
and i won't spam you and send out about
one email a week
with the advice tips tricks and things
that are going about and percolating in
the multiverse of minds that i'm
connecting together
in the spirit of pandemic podcasts
so for now sit back and enjoy this
wonderful
fun raucous at times interview with
the brilliant effervescent and
imaginative frankwell check
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
okay welcome everybody to this episode
of the into the impossible podcast
i am your fearful host dr brian keating
in this time of pandemic podcasting
and we're so fortunate to be joined
today by a friend
a real legend uh and and so such a
generous
uh person uh as frank wilcheck he's
given
a lot of his time to this podcast and
and he's one of the most popular guests
that we've had
so it's quite fitting that we kind of
return the favor in our small little way
and have him back on the occasion
of his phenomenal new book called
fundamentals and we'll be talking a lot
about that today frank how are you
feeling today
i'm feeling pretty good you've had a lot
of uh great publicity
on this wonderful new book we'll be
talking about fundamentals it's very
gratifying it really has been very
gratifying you know
among all my book experiences this has
been
unique it's really been i think
i think i've been supplying something
that people
really needed even if they didn't know
it
well i i see you as a wanted
wanted i should say wanted not needed
wanted even before i didn't realize it
well in this case i see you as as having
tremendous amount of courage you've
always been
a courageous physicist and a
physicist with style and an actual um
sort of i would say a brand which is
extremely high quality
but somehow with extremely high quantity
and i want to get into that first
how what is your what's the day in the
life of frank wilcheck like now
now you talked about in your previous
books you talked about your devotion to
your wife
and betsy and then you've talked about
your kids and this is the first book you
talk about your grandchild
which is so exciting congratulations
that's the first opportunity yeah
that's right how how have things changed
i didn't i didn't hold that in reserve
yeah the new release came out the time
with the book launch i actually had that
with my twins they came out
a week before my book came out but frank
what how has your
style changed since becoming a
grandfather or
has it changed is your workflow has your
daily routine changed at all
well not so much be because of
uh having a grandchild that's been a
blessing and has
suddenly off altered my view of the
world i guess or not so something
viewing him learning and uh establishing
a self
and a model of the world was very
illuminating and
went very much into fundamentals right
uh but it hasn't
affected my daily life in any very
direct way
what's really affected my daily life is
the pandemic of course which
has meant that the
wandering lifestyle that that i had
somehow fallen into
for the past four or five years uh
uh suddenly stopped and uh
whereas i was moving every few months
stiff to different parts of the world uh
and
that was kind of an adventure and i made
a lot of new friends and it was
fun it was it was not conducive to a
kind of reflective life
and and sustained creative work
and now i've gone sort of
resumed that my style almost like i'm
going back to graduate school it's been
really an extraordinary thing
uh i completed the book
which was kind of you know a struggle
i've been a a troubled uh
pregnancy for quite a while and i got to
relax
and actually give birth to the book
and i've gone back to school in some
ways i've been reading
more both physics and more broadly and
i took up juggling and start been
exercising i lost
now almost 20 pounds yeah i feel feel
younger than i
felt for a very long time uh
more energetic and um
and i'm i've also been
learning things i've i've decided uh you
know
that i could well
i could get serious about machine
learning machine learning and really
dirty my
i've i've for many years now enjoyed
interacting with computer through
mathematica and it's quite
physics modeling and things like that
but
uh it hasn't i uh
i've been interested in machine learning
from a long time for a long time in fact
uh in the history of machine learning
an important event was a workshop at
santa barbara
in the 80s and i was there i was there
and participated in it
not not as one of the central members
certainly but kind of as
an interested quasi spectator and i
wrote to some of the postdocs
and uh and now it's
some of those same ideas about neural
nets have
become deep learning and
have become very very powerful and
impressive yeah
so i decided uh it's time to get back in
touch with that and get up to date
and you know when i when i do something
like that i really mean it so
you know i'm learning how to use the
tools and
and doing model problems and things so
well going back to school in that sense
but also
i i've been carrying through uh
a research program that is uh
i think very interesting and promising
in in many directions
yeah it's that that's that's more like
what i've always done
uh but i've just had more time to do it
yeah well i i made a vow that anybody
who comes out of this
pandemic with a six-pack i'm going to be
quite upset with
and so you might you might add six-pack
to nobel laureate
uh but speaking of no of a novel nova
laureates your fellow
laureate kip thorne uh keeps uh keeps
giving me the cold shoulder to come on
the podcast i've had on
your colleague ray weiss i've had on
barry barish and he keeps saying
i cannot come on just now please contact
me in a couple weeks because it's the
most productive i've ever been
i'm turning down every opportunity to uh
to go on podcasts and i'm just focusing
on work and it's been one of the best
things that ever happened to me
uh in a work sense obviously what is up
what he's up to well the writing book uh
barry and ray and kip are writing a book
about ligo
and i think he's also working on other
projects related to
uh general relativity and so forth but
um but i do want to get into your
newfound peregrinations into the world
of
artificial intelligence it's funny this
book really goes on a journey
from you know natural intelligence uh
through your contributions
all the way up to artificial
intelligence maybe we'll start there
um i you you talk a lot about about
things in the book
and and it was funny because i was
setting up to do this interview i had to
do one of these captchas you know these
captchas where you
you have to prove that you're a human
being but actually you're proving that
you're not
a robot which are not artificial
intelligence which is the opposite of
the turing test right
turing test is you want to prove that
you're a that a general artificial
intelligence can
replicate so i had on noam chomsky this
past year or last year now
and uh and he thinks this whole notion
of you know can machines think
is as outlandish as touring ever did
which is that it's sort of nonsensical
it's almost semantic
you put a lot of faith in it and and you
put a lot of um emphasis on it rather in
the book and i'm wondering what are your
current thoughts
yeah well it's to me it's not a matter
of faith it's
it's uh it's a hypothesis which seems
very very
uh difficult to avoid uh francis crick
the great
molecular biologist called wrote a book
called the astonishing hypothesis around
this very idea
and his formulation was a little bit
different but but
basically it's the idea that mind
emerges from matter
and uh that's certainly been the working
hypothesis of neurobiology and
understanding nervous systems and
and signaling and so forth in the brain
and so far it hasn't hit any show
stoppers
we also as physicists know that when we
do delicate experiments
we have to rations and shielding from
radio waves and shielding
from temperature variations and moisture
or stray graduate students wandering
through the lab
or theorists but one thing one thing
we've never had to correct for
is the possibility that people thinking
about it would affect the results
and to me
yeah anyone who thinks that
there are souls or that there's there's
separate entities that are not described
by the physical laws we know
uh show me you know here here's an open
invitation to uh
devise and experiment with very very
delicate exp
uh instruments and um
you know show the influence of mind on
matter
but we wouldn't i mean we yeah when
you're
just to show that the accuracy of
experiments somehow runs out because
there's a lot of
cosmic noise from the force that's
that's carrying all these thought waves
it's just
uh so so it would be pretty astonishing
so so that there doesn't seem to be
anything
resembling the idea of a thought wave
that can that can affect matter
on the one hand and on the other hand
as i mentioned so far neurobiology has
succeeded in understanding more and more
about
uh signaling memory thinking all the
functions that go into
human information processing and uh
also just the basic fact that thought
seems to be rooted in brains when you
damage brains you damage thought and so
forth
uh and then on the third hand
uh we've learned to make
minds with computers that do very
impressive
things uh all the way from perception
now where they can start to identify
objects in images uh to of course
playing go and chess better than
humans those were once thought to be the
sort of pinnacles of
human intelligence
and in that case there's no question
that the minds have emerged from matter
in fact we designed them and we designed
them based on
the principles of quantum mechanics and
uh and logic
to to uh to do these things and
uh so on all those grounds
i think it's very hard it would be to me
would be astonishing if
if crick's astonishing hypothesis were
not true
but one thing that interesting is me is
is not whether or not
you know computers as you point out like
alpha zero and
and so forth can beat humans at the game
of chess
or at the game of go can they ever
create the game of chess or create the
game of go and this gets at my
my pet peeve lately which is that i'm
not so i don't care about artificial
intelligence
i want artificial wisdom wisdom is
creating chess
knowledge is beating the human at chest
so what do you think about the prospects
for a computer to create a game that
would be pleasurable for human beings
not just
beat us at it well that remains to be
seen
and i do i think a great challenge which
is mentioned in the book and i think
is a very important one is to
make machines unhappy makes machines
want to explore you know to be motivated
to go out and not just not just wait for
instructions but to go out
and explore do things
to uh now there are hints of that i mean
there's a there's something called
reinforcement learning
which is a strategy where
by a computer is encouraged to explore
as well as exploit also to explore and
make mistakes so that it learns what
works and what doesn't work
uh at present that's mostly
implemented in very limited domains of
uh
learning how to play games well or in
robotics learning how to
move around in simple situations but
i don't think there's any barrier of
principle
to uh you know and have having
computers watch humans and watch what
they do
and watch what they like and learn what
their motivations are and then to
uh take over some of them and take over
or not take
takeovers maybe an unfortunate phrase
but to adopt
some of them right and and and use them
uh and derive pleasure from them
and the other thing is when you talk
about creativity
uh it's
again it's creeping up on us but you
may have seen uh things like
this this person does not exist
where you click you can get
photographic in style images
of people that don't exist that are very
convincing very photorealistic
and so these are creations yeah and and
uh there are also programs
now that uh can take an image and turn
it into the style of van gaal
or turn it into the style of picasso at
different periods
and uh okay they're not quite there yet
but
they're uh they can do a lot better than
i can that's for sure
and uh and and then if you leave them to
their own devices they have their own
style which is kind of
phantasmagoric you can look inside
images that uh deep neural nets are
making and and
and uh they have a weird
charm and certainly creative in the
sense that no human artist
does anything like that right no
when i think about that i mean my father
used to say you know one one
promising avenue might be to replicate
how we learn things
which is by pain avoidance right so you
can actually damage the transistors you
know they make a wrong
choice i wonder if they would actually
come about learning but
but you know i always point out and you
talk about this a lot in the book you
know the
that what science has taught us is
tremendous amount of knowledge and i
see this book as helping us synthesize
in the sense that isaac newton as you
describe in the book
would do analysis and then synthesis but
i wonder you know can you ever
broach that you know blood brain barrier
between
knowledge and wisdom in other words i i
see a lot of
a lot of issues with with with the fact
that we trust
scientists and we say scientists
so-and-so has a nobel prize and
and therefore we should trust them
outside of their domain of expertise
that's not a good reason to trust
anybody i've had experience with nobel
prize winners and they
they're very uh they're a very odd lot
and
some are better than others i guess
but i'm sorry yeah no i i'm actually
working on a book where i'm going to
synthesize all the
all the nobel laureates i've spoken to
including you so look for that coming
out this year but
um but in reality i see this this
conflation of knowledge and wisdom
and and i see your book as giving
ammunition and giving a positive way
uh to people to think about the the
limits of knowledge but also inspire
them
you know it's your it's your i would say
it's your least technical of all the
books you've written i think you've
written
oh yes four books it's the most
accessible it's the most
awe inspiring and wonder inspiring it's
full of jokes
uh it's full of little pithy footnotes
which you know
usually they say you know footnotes are
like receiving a phone call as you're
kissing your wife or something but but
now it's like our husband
or whatever i i insisted i insisted that
the footnotes not be numbered
yes i love them they're asynchronous
they're asynchronous and also that they
just appear right there so you don't
have to
thumb through the book to get the and
the footnotes are not you know not
citations
right i think i don't think there's a
single citation in the footnotes but
uh but kind of side remarks jokes as you
say
yeah it's a very accessible it's very
readable for the for the average lay
person
and but also for the technically minded
person you have some you know red meat
or tofu whatever you want to call it for
the vegetarians that may be listening
in the back you've got your feynman
diagrams don't worry there's there's
plenty of technical
uh goodness there let me start with your
current thinking
about really the fundamental
fundamentals what are the most
fundamental fundamentals you start off
with space
with time with experience with genes
what is there you know as george orwell
said you know all animals are equal
some are more equal than others is there
are is anything
as fundamental everything is equally
fundamental but is there something more
fundamental
well in order to have a clear discussion
of this question we have to have a clear
discussion of what
fundamental means and fundamental can
mean a lot of different things that
means
it means a very different thing to an
even geological christian than it means
in the context that i'm using it
but what i mean by fundamentals
for purposes of fundamentals ten keys to
reality
is basic principles
that explain a lot but that can't be
explained in terms of anything else
so for instance the second law of
thermodynamics
is a very insightful profound
principle that tells you a lot about how
the world works but it's not fundamental
in my sense
because we can understand it on the
basis
of atomic structure and concepts of
probability and
uh you know the the the
mechanical view of the world if you like
broadly consider it we can we can
see how it arises uh cosmology also
comes into it
actually because you have to understand
why we happen to find low entropy states
all over the place but but that's the
side
that's another issue anyway uh but
so what i mean by fundamental is
basic principles
about how the world works that cannot be
explained in terms of more basic
principles
but and the fact that there are such
things and that there are just
a small number of them that you can
survey
uh is a profound profound discovery
that in itself and then
spelling out exactly what there are that
they are is also interesting
but the most profound thing is that
there are such are such a few principles
that
that uh that you can that you know
just like einstein said the the most
incomprehensible
thing about the world is that it's
comprehensible or what he actually said
is that uh
it was i think it was in german
originally but a pretty good
translation would be the
comprehensibility of the world is a
miracle
[Laughter]
and yet we have uh plenty of plenty of
people wanting to make it comprehensible
i think um when when i read the book i
come across
first of all you know it's not simply
touting
accomplishments and so forth that you
personally made although you have made
contributions to this when you decide
that a problem is worth your attention i
mean
it seems like you've stored in in some
memory bank in your brain uh the fact
that machine learning
is interesting and you happen to be at
this you know apocaly conference in
santa barbara et cetera
so what what makes you decide that um
it's time to write a book or it's time
to pick up a new
project and perhaps leave you know
particle physics qcd behind for
cosmology and dark matter how do you
decide that what is that
is there a rubric or it's just whatever
happens to interest you
well it's somewhere in between i think
there's
there's certainly an element of
playfulness i mean i like to say my
operating system is think play
repeat so
so i think about something then i play
around with the ideas and
then think about it again and repeat and
see if see if
they get better uh but
uh but i guess there are
two basic factors plus a third
kind of ingredient that goes into this
process
so the basic factors are uh
the importance of a problem and
uh and and the
percep my perception that i think i can
do something about it
so so there are some problems that are
and but then the third thing i wanted to
say is you have to
what is what is a lot is a lot of weight
there is being put on the word important
how do you decide what's important
uh okay so things can be important in
different ways things can be important
if they're
fundamental as we discussed things can
be important if they have
the possibility of doing useful
things in the world and we can allow a
very broad definition of useful like
pushing the frontiers of knowledge in
some way or making something observable
that was only latent about the world
to me is important and then uh
then there's the third thing which is
just making things more beautiful it's
more aesthetic
that the improving the description of
the world people if i
perceive flaws here and there that's
something that i've often uh
you know perceive flaws or gaps in our
understanding of the world
so so that's the third so that's that's
kind of the third factor which you might
you might say jokingly is irritation if
something irritates me
that that's important
important addressable and irritating
those are the three
axes all right well we've got a note
that's
uh that's a keynote for this talk uh tag
uh it has to be important
uh interesting and irritating right the
three eyes was it
but i want to ask you something when you
came up with axions i mean axions aren't
particularly beautiful except in the
sense that they might solve a problem so
they're not beautiful in the direct
sense that you know your equations are
it's more important that they're
beautiful than that they're right
because i don't agree with that the
equations are quite beautiful
um that the uh
yeah they they turn out to be a when you
boil it down
and well the original model
implementations were not particularly
beautiful and
i should you know to this day there's no
really beautiful derivation
of the basic principles of axion physics
they
are tied up in questions of unification
where we just don't know
enough detail to pin it all down
but if you do
kind of abstract away that you can get a
very
beautiful set of equations which are
kind of a minimal extension
of maxwell's equations to include
one extra scalar field and
now that i think about it i never
thought about it this way but it's like
in a way it's like bran's dicky theory
which is a famous extension of general
relativity to include an extra light
scaler
uh but this is much better motivated
and much uh much better uh
and i think the equations are more
beautiful and
it's not just me that thinks that nature
thinks it it turns out that
these very equations uh
govern the behavior of certain states of
matter in a in a very
profound sense they are the effective
theories
of low energy you know with different
names on the symbols and different
values of the parameters
but the same equations they govern the
behave
the behavior of low energy excitations
and the interactions of certain
materials with matter that the so-called
topological insulators in fact are
examples of axion electrodynamics and
i'm very proud that i wrote a paper
back in the 80s i believe called two
applications of axion electrodynamics
and in that paper you will find the
equations
that govern topological insulators even
though i didn't know anything about
topological insulin
no but you know they were still still
not even a gleam in the eye of anybody
but but the equations have a life of
their own
when we look at their very beautiful
questions yeah when we look at and also
another aspect of it so i'm i'm sorry
i'm getting exercise because you said
that axions aren't beautiful
i just said the problem of spontaneous
image i mean obviously the most
beautiful thing is
is perfect symmetry right so they don't
have perfect symmetry
when i was first thinking about these
things i really didn't
uh anticipate that uh
there would be an important connection
to cosmology right
and yet it turns out that the equations
are
again there's more in them than than we
knew and
uh it turns out that very plausibly
the axions make up the dark matter that
cosmologists need
and we'll see right we'll see
that the reason i said it's not
beautiful i just said the underlying
symmetry
is broken and and and in fact i think
most people equate you know perfect
symmetry with perfect beauty so that's
the only reason i'm saying
that you were guided by uh-huh yeah
yes well but it's broken in a very very
particular way
right so the way that it's broken is
it's it's i would say yes it's broken
it's a broken symmetry so it's an
imperfect symmetry
but i would say uh it's an opportunity
to expand
your concept of symmetry so that
that nature gives you a uh
a an opportunity to expand your mind by
expanding your concept of what asymmetry
means from the vulgar idea that it has
to be perfect
to the idea that that it can be sort of
violated in a very particular way but
let me
let me not let that go though because
yeah it's actually also
true of asymptotic freedom
asymptotic freedom you know scale and
variance is a possible
uh symmetry of the world that you know
that the
the laws could look the same if you make
everything bigger
and that's definitely not true of
gravity it's definitely not true of
other laws but it's almost true of the
equations of qcd
that their scale invariant and and that
was really
one of the important clues that led us
to those equations
was to try to get as close to that
symmetry as we can
and asymptotic freedom shows the
asymptotic
is that that symmetry appears
more and more clearly as you go to
higher and higher energy
and shorter and shorter distances so
it's another kind of symmetry that's
never fully realized
but is violated in a very structured way
and can be fully revealed
kind of as a limiting uh perspective
limiting
uh a behavior right so
symmetry yeah so uh
i find it really delightful and even
more beautiful
when you have an expanded concept of
symmetry that that can
uh that can be applied in new ways
right yeah and we have doing there are
other examples
but broken symmetry is is uh
both bro i said broken symmetry is not
simply the absence of symmetry
you can have approximate symmetry you
can have spontaneously broken symmetry
you can have
anomalous symmetry you can have uh
symmetry broken by by quant by uh
asymptotic symmetry so all the we
symmetry has been a dominant uh
motif or a dominant theme of
especially 20th century physics not just
because it's sometimes completely
realized
but because it has all these
possibilities for fruitful
generalization
and nature likes it nature likes them
that's you know
it would have been very hard for people
to dream of them but but nature
led us to them right i always point out
there's a famous
um there's a famous study or where they
take uh the most handsome man in the
world
i was busy that day so they took brad
pitt
they took brad pitt and they take his
face and they cut it down the middle
and then they reflect the right side
onto the left side left side and he's
grotesque
uh you know even more than he normally
is and so perfect
yeah perfect symmetry is not beautiful
at least a human conception
and i want to talk about you know how
the human beings come in come into play
in this book because we live
sorry that's another theme in music you
you don't play this
you do theme with variations and that
enriches
the effect right yeah and counterpoint
and so forth yes uh
i say the only instrument i play is the
iphone that's the only one i'm competent
hi everybody just a quick break to
remind you to subscribe to my newsletter
at briankeating.com
and also like subscribe leave a review
an asterism a constellation of stars
ranging from one to five i hope on the
five side but it's up to you if you
think i could do better
i read each and every one here i'll read
one right now
just to prove to you that i do read each
and every review that i am blessed to
get by you my listening audience so
here's a recent one
that i got brian keating is a no no that
is not that's from mom
how could you do that that's that's
awful uh but no there's uh this is a
hidden gem
a wonderful resource uh this is
a review this is given by i don't see
the name but
i do read all the names another one is
by someone named
sib canack and he or she says no
pretension or repetition to fear
thank you sibonac brian is uh as a
podcaster actually he or she calls me
brain as a podcaster thank you sivanak
that's why i have that name because
people confuse me with someone with a
brain
but brian as a podcaster and moderator
holds easily the balance between the
known and the unknown
in a way that socially engages the
listener without insulting the intellect
a great discovery on my part thank you
so much
another one from lalo san 16 dr keating
is a very well prepared host
that keeps the conversation professional
and gives the welcoming sensation to the
listeners
it takes time to read a lot of the
research in books by the way i read
every book
i read 52 books in the last year alone
and i loved every one of them
so thank you for that tyler says brian
gets great guests asked great questions
and is brave enough to speak
to a wide variety of people and ask them
questions that many in academia
often shy away from thank you very much
everybody i never shy away i never dumb
it down
and i always encourage academic freedom
so please do subscribe but leave a
review it really helps me i'm trying to
keep it ad free
for the time being and i will do so uh
if you guys continue to leave
me some feedback and subscribe to the
newsletter so briankeating.com
there it is right there and uh and do me
that a wonderful favor
i appreciate it very much and now back
to the remainder of our conversation
with the
uh with the noblest mind of the nobel
mines universe now it's there's many
many uh nobel laureates that have come
on and many that aren't
so it's it's quite a treat but today a
special treat because it's the it's the
book launch for frank wilchick's
fundamentals pick up a copy
i'll have a link in the show notes and
you can get one yourself and you will
enjoy it
and it's a rather quick read which i
appreciate having so many books to read
so many awesome guests coming up and
really just so blessed to run this
podcast thank you so much
enjoy the rest of the show i think
another aspect of this book we talked a
little bit about that with deepak chopra
and leonard milan now
is you know kind of cosmic humility that
we're sort of in this
you know uh we're sort of at this
geometric mean
between the largest scales in the
universe or i don't know exponential
logarithmic geometric mean maybe
between the largest scales in the
universe and the smallest scales
is that is that you know sort of as
galileo pointed out you know animals can
only be so large you can't have an
elephant the size of
you know the leaning tower of pisa is is
that just an accident is there some
anthropic
you know kind of correlation you you
talk about the you know the variety of
scales as
as another type of fundamental property
of our universe can you talk more about
that
well it's complicated and i think it's
time dependent
uh but yes the scale the the size that
we are
is we're we're in a very sweet spot
actually we are large enough to come
to comprehend a
a very you know a very large number in
the objective objective sense much much
larger than one
uh of independent processing units
neurons
that are themselves complicated and
stable so they're composed of zillions
of
to speak scientifically billions of
atoms and molecules you heard it here
nobel laureate uses zillions and
conjunctive support they support complex
patterns and information processing that
that we call mind
and yet we don't exhaust
no one of us or or even humanity as a
whole
does not come close to exhausting the
resources of the physical universe
or here on this little planet inside
this
modest solar system inside a
average galaxy inside a huge universe
and maybe a multiverse on top of that
maybe uh so uh
so we're we're both large in the sense
of
uh having enough
uh independent
complexity pro programmable complexity
if you like or
dynamic complexity to support very
rich experience and information
processing
and all the wonderful things that come
with being human
and yet uh there's a lot left over
so that in the future uh the
the vanguard of intelligence can can
keep expanding
and uh and that now
we get into the dreams of science
fiction like olaf stapleton of galactic
brains and
and things which of course uh
are still the future and they may take a
long time to be realized if ever
but uh but we're in a sense we're
starting to get there we're sending out
we're establishing uh the whole world
as a communications network you know i
can talk to you
across the continent with that you don't
give it a second thought anymore but you
know use
i mean i'm old enough to remember when
that was not
remotely a possibility when it was you
know
now you have a studio now you've got
your own home studio
all right that's right and uh
and you know we can send out
robots that are complex and actuators to
different planets and explore them
and we can so we have intimate
uh and it's gonna get better and better
they sort of out of i've had some out of
body experiences controlling robots in
other places and being embodied and
having conversations with people
and uh it's a very it's a transporting
experience literally
and that i think the the idea of
distributed intelligence
both uh as a continuation
of sort of you individual human identity
but also kind of a group
consciousness uh is is on us
and it's it's only it's and it's gonna
flourish and
so we're not limited by the size of a
human body
so that so that okay so that i guess
that's that's what that's all i wanted
to touch on
we are very big we are also very small
and we're growing those are the three
points i think right
and the universe is growing too although
given your diet and your loss of weight
you're shrinking
and i'm growing but we're conserved i'm
conserving the amount of mass between
you
and me my shell is getting smaller but
my brain is getting bigger
that's the most efficient packing
mechanism i actually talked to
astronaut jessica meer not too long ago
and she said not only are
you know women you know kind of better
suited to go into space because they
have a higher strength to weight ratio
especially in space
but they actually have slower
metabolisms so that makes them
more efficient consumers of energy and
i'm thinking
yeah but their their brains might work a
lot faster than our brains as men
and so uh yes there might be a triple
threat for women to
so hopefully she'll be the first woman
to set foot on the moon she's uh
she's an amazing amazing person i want
to ask you a question that i've always
wanted to ask you
you're a theorist uh you you delve into
you know the the observational
consequences of your theories
what is the most beautiful experiment or
maybe one or two experiments that you've
ever
seen in the history of let's say modern
physics let's not go back to you know
cavendish or whatever
let's stay with modern physics last 100
years or so oh i thought you were going
to ask about
the things that came out of my theories
well let me start with those anyway
yeah yeah i will okay go ahead start
with us because
there's a personal element to it and i
don't want to give up on that right away
yeah okay then i'll come back to the
most beautiful period
uh so to me uh
the two most beautiful experiments that
kind of
relate spoke to me on a personal level
because they came out of my work in some
sense
are seeing jets in qcd
where you almost literally see the final
diagrams that we calculated
with quarks and gluons and antiquarks
not as individual particles but you see
their tracks as
where you see several parts several
actual particles moving fast in the same
direction
and so it plots out a flow of energy and
momentum that tracks the properties of
the underlying quarks and gluons
and it is incred i mean you know i
remember distinctly as a graduate
students
playing with these feynman diagrams and
and
doing the algebra and uh
the idea that this would actually be
a tangible almost like a map
of the physical world is is just just
mind-boggling and and but there it is
and so that's that's one beautiful kind
of experiment
and uh and the other was much more
recent kind of a book end to the to
the beginning and so far the latest
chapter
like is uh was the enion discovery where
uh the antion observation where we
predicted
that in a certain state of matter uh
the emergent particles would have some
peculiar kind of memory that
if you have one and what the other one
another one winds around it that affects
its behavior
and uh this this summer
june or july uh an experiment
was done that actually saw this behavior
and and uh
uh it would take a bit of patience
on my part and also more important on
your audience's part
to fully to fully explain it but uh
you see certain curves that have
discontinuities
when one or an or two or three you know
it's an integer number of these
funny particles that fall into your trap
and each time they do you see a change
in the behavior
that's discontinuous and it's
extraordinarily beautiful
and the experimentalists did a good job
of
false coloring and
that sort of presentation of their data
so it just leaps to the eye and it's
it's uh
uh it's just an extraordinary um
correspondence between reality and
theoretical understanding
that was uh very beautiful uh that
so now going back to your so those are
the two
for me in my personal experience that
have just
you know sent me into a a different
state of consciousness
i was walking on air
for several days when i saw these things
never fully came down
uh
then uh uh
but if i think about the most beautiful
kind of phenomenon that
uh sort of is
you know i don't want to go back to
ancient history or something
and it's it's you know it's hard to hard
to not take that for grant
these things for granted like newton's
laws of gravity and so
or even general relativity uh
so novelty is also an element of
of beauty and to me the most beautiful
kind of experiment that
emerged from 20th century physics is the
josephson effect
the hasty of the josephson effects that
are these extraordinary manifestations
of
behavior of matter and the
superconducting state when you have
little insulating layers between two and
silicon two superconductors so something
you would never
ever stumble onto without
profound understanding intuitions
about the behavior of matter uh when
quantum mechanics dominates its behavior
and really stunningly surprising
behavior that a constant voltage gives
rise to a non-constant current
and then as the icing on the cake so
it's rooted mathematically and deep
principles of gauge symmetry and sort of
quantum mechanics at its most
raw basic uh fundamental
uh level and and
uh and it's led to a an important
technology
a very important technology that i don't
think is exhausted yet
no we use it in all of our detectors in
cosmology
yes right right so so that to me
may be the most beautiful yeah it's hard
to believe it's coming up on about 60
years of
of josephine effect uh for me it's the
aharonov bomb effect because
it's so strange you know that this thing
that we
we ascribe almost no reality to in
classical physics
then not only seems to have a reality in
in physics as a whole but also in
quantum physics
and and they're not unrelated i suppose
to the justice and effect where it's a
phase dependent effect it's also not
unrelated to and it's very related to
anions
yes yeah so actually can you can we take
a little break because it's not so
often i get a chance to um to ask
someone of your stature
the most basic questions of life so um
when
when you think of these things is it is
it that you are
you know kind of is is it that fortune
favors a prepared mind
is it that you've you worked so hard as
a young person
and and you paid your dues and and you
put in your
100 000 hours and then
all of a sudden these ideas just flow to
you are you an idea machine
how what what is your kind of a secret
is there anything that we can learn from
you let me just put it that
way is there any habitual i
i think i love to learn things and then
so it's not work for me and
uh i've always been kind of a sponge of
absorbing
i'm not so good at systematically saying
oh i'm going to study this and then
you know without
without uh how should i say without
loving it already
i but but i fortunately for me for my
career i love a lot of ideas
and then just dig deeper and uh i've
been very
fortunate in uh going to the right
schools and meeting some
very uh
great thinkers that i was in resonance
with you know all the way from bertrand
russell to
to herman wild to david gross and each
time
uh uh learning something new and a
different
in uh uh einstein and feynman you know
the the old
and uh darwin you know
they're you didn't meet darwin though
right no i didn't eat darwin
you're like the youngest nobel prize
winner nor did i meet
i didn't meet einstein either although
you know
he died when i was four years old or
something right so i could have met him
but colleague here who did meet him
lymon
lyman spitzer's son is a professor here
nick spitzer at uc san diego and he
remembers seeing him
you know rowing in a rowboat and
einstein you know
at the institute for advanced study um i
see you also working
well you do work with it but i mentioned
that i'm learning artificial
intelligence
and machine learning now in a serious
way and over the years i've
i've uh i've maintained an amateur
interest in that i
i had an amateur interest in cosmology
so that went which i was able to
heighten when it became clear that the
emerging ideas and high energy physics
could be used for cosmology
uh i had kind of an amateur interest in
the rest of physics that was not
fundamental particles
but then when i realized that the
insights that we were developing in
particle physics
could be applied in this be to
describe interesting new phenomena in in
matter
i took i educated myself more
systematically than that and so
so so it's a combination of sort of
general awareness
of what's out there uh
and occasional obsessions or
sensed opportunities that i seize on
but so i think the thing
i mean okay i can't speak for everybody
or
even for anybody really except myself
but
but to me it seems to me looking at
other people what
sep one thing that separates my style
from
others is that uh i'm kind of an
omnivore of
ideas i just i uh i graze in all kinds
of different directions
but you're not a dilettante i mean
there's a danger you could be
yeah no it's serious i have a serial
attention on
that goes you know when i when i
well i don't think i'm a dilemma
i i uh that's just what a dilite would
say
i i i put honest work
and into every single paper that i've
written and i've written a lot
uh so i go very deeply at least for the
time i'm writing the paper
but i do have as you say uh for instance
in qcd
uh i
have delved from time to time back in
particular things like
uh color superconductivity
or
[Music]
notably color superconductivity but also
the phase structure of qcd
and sort of cosmological implications
of qcd but
basically i abandoned the subject
as as a subject in itself and and that's
been my style i do something
you might say skim the cream or do do
make a contribution
that's that i'm happy with and then move
on to something else
and you work with um small groups i
would say
you don't tend to work in huge
collaborations is uh
would you say that you know part of your
success is is
your ability to focus you know
relatively
you know like i always say laser focus
is not actually correct it's laser
collimation when people say laser focus
they mean laser
collimation but um when you collimate
your mind is it best done
by yourself or with a student or two
certain seemingly it's not with large
groups
in uh i've worked in
both ways uh
so
i often when i have a new idea i share
it with
friends and things and and sometimes it
resonates and results in a collaboration
there have been several occasions on
which
where it's worked the other way where
some people have brought me into
their investigations and
and you know if i feel like have and so
it sparked if it sparks my imagination i
i participate if it doesn't then i don't
uh so usually it only it really only
usually sparks my imagination if it's
something i've been at least
close to thinking about or
related to things that i have been
thinking about
so but yeah i
always looking for new adventures
but i also say some of them are
self-generated
but self-generated means based on
reading that i've done
or annoyances that i felt about the way
things
should be that and aren't
but also sparked by conversations with
colleagues
uh sometimes by colloquia or seminars
yes just i'm uh
my mind is open as as urdosha
say that's right said that except and he
also said when they took away his
his amphetamines for a month they said
he said that you set back
you set back the progress of mathematics
by one month but
i know that's not a problem for you i do
want to close out by
uh talking a little bit in the book one
of the things that really
resonates with me in your writing and in
your speaking
is that you have a courage and i think
you know for scientists nowadays to even
mention something from the gospel of
mark i mean it shouldn't take
courage to do that but you do it and and
i wonder
when you write things in the book you
quote from matthew and mark
and you quote uh you know these other
kind of astonishing
things you know from from feel
theistically inclined individuals shall
we say
but my and and i am as you know
i called myself i was an altar boy in
the catholic church but i'm
born as a jew and i practice as a jew
i'm not afraid
i have a bit of that too actually of
jewishness
yes i didn't know that i thought you
were a polish catholic
no well i was but you know
a lot of polish catholics weren't
entirely
catholic by choice or it was complicated
yeah and my grand my paternal
grandfather was jewish
what do you think yeah and uh he wasn't
he didn't practice in any way either
catholicism or judaism but
that's that's another story that's not
uncommon that that's that's
my question is you know can religion
does religion inform you in any way i
read the bible
every day i read a section of it of the
old testament only
uh you know because it's part of the
jewish tradition we read the whole torah
the old testament once per year
and every day there's one seventh of a
weekly portion that we read
and so for me it's it's always i always
look to it and i say you know is this
scientific i wrestle with it
is this not scientific and i remember
this conversation i had with milot now
not too long ago
and we were talking about uh stephen
hawking's uh famous book a brief history
of time
which when i read it i didn't understand
i was only 17 or something when it came
out 18 16.
but uh but now i understand it really
well and i understand what he was trying
to do
in that book which was really to make
the case for god's existence
not necessary not to invalidate god's
existence but
he talked about the two reasons for god
would be to establish the laws of nature
you know basically establish
the laws of nature as well and the laws
of physics by which he meant that
but but really also to establish the
universe as a whole and
what he said was you know god could be
avoided
the necessity of starting the universe
if the hawking hardle conjecture
is true the no boundary conjecture and
that was really the basis of the book
frank i urge you to read that book again
because
he's really saying that that is not
controversial and it still is
controversial
but the second thing he says is of
course well
yeah okay i would say it's not even
controversial but that's another
question
that's right that's what uh paulie used
to say what not even wrong
but uh right but uh but but then he said
that
m theory in the grand design with
leonard malod now
he says that m theory provides the
conditions for the
laws of nature and so in both instant
instantiations of god's necessity it's
not now
again i am a practicing devout agnostic
i'm agnostic as they come
but i think it's important to wrestle
with these well what does the
what does you know your study your
knowledge of religion what does it
um does it do something does it satisfy
something in you that your equations
cannot
is it just philosophy what is religion
to you i mean let me let me first say
that
uh i do not adhere to any
uh any established religion right
i was brought i when i was growing up
in into my early teen years
i was absolutely fascinated and deeply
steeped
in roman catholicism which i was exposed
so i
a lot of my cultural heritage is from
that
and so that's why i can you know i refer
to it
because it's part of why my intellectual
furniture so to speak
and i still have a lot of respect and
admiration for that tradition
uh it's it's quite flawed it's quite
complicated and human but that contains
some very beautiful things
and broadly considered the whole
judeo-christian
tradition uh is you know is
part of who we are if we grow up and as
you and i did in the in
in the 20th century and 21st century
united states
just it is it is it's everywhere around
us and uh
so so it's it's it's
part you know it's
to to uh uh
ignore it or minimize it or uh
uh attempt to uh
uh how should i say stigmatize it or is
it was it's like cutting off your arm or
doing a lobotomy a part of you
you don't you lose a lot if
if you lose that cultural reference and
and there
are things about uh getting around in
the world and making sense of it
that science doesn't answer you know
fame
i i very much agree with david yum's
analysis that
no no amount of thinking about what is
can lead to a logical inference about
what ought to be you know or how we
ought to behave or what's why right
so uh it can
give you insight about the consequences
of different choices and
you know lead to a kind of wisdom at
that level but it can't ultimately
decide what what you want to do or
what's right or what's good what's bad
those are different categories uh and
people have thought about those things
for a lot of time a lot long time
gathered a lot of experience and a lot
of that
is in traditions and
uh including religious ones so
i mean this is a rambling answer but the
uh
the so i i think it's it's it's
uh not a good idea
to to just uh ignore or dump on or
trivialize those traditions i think
in the spirit of complementarity you can
learn from them right and also
relate better to people who come from
different perspectives
if you uh take it seriously and try to
understand
um what what they're thinking about uh
but to me sort of the the approach to
those
questions that's proved most sympathetic
and fulfilling
in the long run to me is to understand
god through god's works
to understand uh you know what what it's
all about what it all means by first
understanding what it
is and then and then that teaches you a
lot
about those other questions uh
certainly is his background knowledge
you should have to approach them
uh with seriousness they deserve and so
that that that's
that's what i've been that's what i've
been trying to do and that's certainly
what i try to convey in fundamentals
yeah yeah towards the end of the book
we're coming to the end of the
conversation i know you've got a lot of
media appearances from your home studio
uh the reporters outside uh but i do
want to cover a couple things then you
promised me an answer
last time to a question i asked all my
guests when we spoke in november
uh and so i want to get to that question
in just a second but before we go there
they the book kind of i don't i hate it
when authors are asked to you know
summarize your entire book so the
audience doesn't have to buy the
the uh the book or the audio book so i i
will listen to this book i have a copy
of the book obviously
and uh maybe we'll give a copy away to
one of my listeners
uh depending on uh depending on how you
feel i'd love to get a signed copy
someday
but i do want to ask you at the end of
the book you talk about complementarity
and right before that you talk about
complexity and emerging complexity
i spoke to your crosstown your crosstown
rival i have avi loeb
uh last week about his new book called
extraterrestrial
and he talks a lot in that book about
this technology that he believes visited
our solar system
back in 2017 but a good portion of the
book it
yeah you find that astonishing
what's that are you there i said oh my
gosh yes
yeah i'm there that's what it says he
says yes the baby
is the extraterrestrial student
well the first thing i want to ask you
uh
yeah the first thing i want to do is as
ask you about that um
not that hypothesis you'll have to read
the book as i did but
um but if complexity is an emergent
property of the universe
um first of all do you believe there is
uh the you know that there will be found
evidence for extraterrestrial
intelligence is there a preponderance of
evidence
is that unanswerable and second of all
would they have structures like religion
and extraterrestrial civilizations if
they do exist if complexity is a
fundamental
feature of the union
yes well okay to the first question of
course
well okay unless there's something i
don't know about that doesn't seem
that i'd say the situation is we don't
have direct evidence for
any kind of extraterrestrial
intelligence
however to me the probabilities
are overwhelming there's a kind of
circumstantial
reasons to suspect that it should be
abundant and
uh and it's not a paradox that we
haven't seen it because it's far away
and difficult to communicate uh
and also uh when i say it's abundant i
should say what it is
okay so here on earth uh
we know that as soon as the conditions
became
not crazy so to speak as soon as the
earth began to solidify and
and cool down and have a reasonable
degree of stability
and form uh liquid oceans and so forth
it didn't take very long for a life to
emerge
and and also you know the chemistry
is complicated but not crazily
complicated to get life started
so i believe it's very likely that
uh life would start on the variety
a large number of the kinds of planets
that people are discovering now extras
extra solar planets
uh in in great abundance so they're not
a rare thing they're
you know again zillions of them in the
galaxy so
have many billions probably of potential
i believe the precise term is gajillion
gajillion frank
in our galaxy and then of course there
are lots and lots of galaxies
uh so i do think that
life is probably is abundant in the
universe
uh however
uh again consulting the history of life
on earth
which uh it took a long time for
multi-cellular life to
emerge and it took you know kind of
special conditions of stability and
uh kind of having a nice
state a nice star that that's uh
that has a leisurely evolution and a
plan of an orbit that's precisely
circular and a moon to kind of stir
things up and play tech
there seem to although you know we can't
say what it would have happened if
any of these things hadn't been in place
it does seem
that the step it seems to me that the
step
from simple life which is sort of at the
level
of glorified chemistry
to multi-cellular reforms
uh is a much as a difficult step then on
earth that took a long long time
right uh that took billions of years
and then on top of that
then uh to get from there to something
we called intelligence
that's that we would recognize as
human level intelligence has only been
realized in humans basically
uh with use of language and abstract
concepts and so
and of course the growth of technology
is only about 200 years old so
and embodied a lot of contingencies
such as wiping out the dinosaurs
yeah i call that the uh the hard problem
of the whale so i think
i think the i think extraterrestrial
intelligence and extraterrestrial
technology might be
rare even though extraterrestrial life
is common
yeah uh but i don't know this is this is
very difficult speculative stuff i do
right no i i agree and that's why it's
so surprising that avi is
so is so convinced with high certainty
that this was alien technology and i
i didn't ask him this question but alien
technology in the sense of physical
objects that
they throw into our vicinity seems to be
extraordinarily far-fetched uh well
that's a very
inefficient way it's a very inefficient
way to explore the universe to act to
throw physical objects around
it takes a very you know it takes a very
long time
and why do it you know and you have to
know where to throw it and so how do you
know it just
it's it just it seems a priori so
far-fetched
well that's what he said you would say
okay that's what he said it's hard to
get excited about ufos or whatever
the uh uh on the other hand you know
there's
arthur c clarke's third law that says
that any sufficiently
advanced technology looks like magic so
who am i to say
what some advanced civilization might be
doing
uh but okay but but i'd need to see
pretty good evidence
right to start thinking those you'll see
that in his book you'll see that in the
podcast about his book which will come
out confusingly
after this podcast comes out but yes
these the saying but
about by arthur c clarke is how we open
this podcast with his actual voice
you'll hear it when you listen to the
podcast tomorrow
but um but i do want to say yeah in that
context first of all he doesn't believe
that it was necessarily targeting earth
he thinks it's sort of space
either space junk or space debris but it
was a solar sail
i don't want to get into that too much
but just to say that elon musk
elon musk right now is preparing that
makes okay but yeah all right well well
yeah this is a definitely a diversion
from our main themes yeah
yeah i mean the question remarkable if
just say let's just say remarkable if
true
that's right astonishing even if false
um
but yes i i talked about this in the
context i brought it up in the context
of you know is complexity
fundamental if complexity is fundamental
as you assert
you know and kind of religion is sort of
a you know
a superstructure built upon you know the
culture
of the evolved citizens i think
yeah i think complexity is is a
i mean we proved we know we are we
proved it we
are it we are the proof really that uh
complexity is a
complex complexity that can support mind
is an emergent property of matter
under the right conditions uh so
to me that's not not a hypothesis that's
just a fact
and uh that uh we proved it in ourselves
we also prove it with our constructions
right uh so but i don't i wouldn't say
it's
a uh a fundamental
feature of matter though it's it's in
the sense in the sense of fundamental
we've discussed that that
can't be uh understood in terms of more
basic principles the
the more basic principles of quantum
field theory and things like that
uh don't themselves refer to complexity
but they
turn out to empower complexity
we talked about um with leonard milan
now and deepak chopra
well in our chat called fundamentally
closer to truth which is on my podcast
channel
and on deepak chopra's chopra well we
got into this kind of
meandering conversation about free will
and so forth and i don't
really want to revisit that but i do
want to say that you know at some point
we were debating
you know if you could know the wave
function
you know for a given uh for a human
being
then you could know predict basically
with absolute certainty
how he or she would interact with the
world and i found it very frustrating
because
uh that presupposes a bunch of things
such as you know we understand the wave
function of the person we understand the
wave function of the universe
and we understand the apparatus as you
make a point in this book
you know precision and um what is it
precision
is sort of complicated precision and
human precision precision and human
comprehensibility
yeah so you have to you have to like
alter
the system to make a precise the more
you uh want precision
in your measurements the more you have
to interact with it so how could you
possibly
anyway i was on your side in that but i
want to ask you a question
i've had debates with people like sean
carroll and so forth about
about religion about the multiverse etc
wherein
you'll hear things like well you know
before the universe
existed even your your co-author you
know lawrence krauss and you have done
written papers together he'll say well
the laws of physics you know allow for a
multiverse therefore the multiverse can
occur but i want to ask you where does
the do you
can we ever know things like
where the wave function of the universe
came from or sean carroll says
you know well there's a hilbert space
and that's all you need okay that's
great but where did the hillbirds face
come from are these like the same kind
of
frustrating stupid questions that i
asked you about free will or
are these fruitful avenues for
discussion because sometimes
you know you know the best part is
knowing when to say no
well so yes yes you kind of know what to
say
this really goes back to the discussion
we had earlier about how i decide what
to work
on and some questions are more fruitful
than others
you know any bum on the street can say
what's it all about and
yeah what's the meaning of it all
and and okay yeah and and uh
you know i wouldn't call the bums but
we've had a long history of philosophers
who
uh even even you know some that are
highly regarded and
still study that to me have had
discussions that are kind of so vague
and so
meandering that they don't lead anywhere
uh so
pseudo-profound i would say but
that doesn't mean there aren't
legitimate questions that are of great
interest
around those issues it's just a matter
of
separating the wheat from the chaff yeah
yeah
when you look at a um when you think
about things like
uh the these sort of impossible to
answer questions that we should
we should have just said you know
citation descartes you know 1687
you know he needs to boost his h index a
little bit uh
but uh but but i guess you know what
fascinates me about your work is that
you don't shy away from the big
questions
but you're actually really keen on
answering you know particular questions
and in fact you say in the book you say
you know if there's
justice in the universe we will find you
know axions
can you tell me what do you mean are you
serious do you feel like that's you know
kind of
like einstein said you know if what's
that i
i i'm not obviously i'm not serious that
it's it's
justice i mean no no i will be guilty of
any crime
i'm not the dark matter but uh
but i but i just mean it would be a pity
if
so much circumstantial evidence
from uh nature you know
uh were misleading
so it's sort of a vast cosmic joke i
think i think
you know i'd like to think that god has
better taste than that
to mislead us that way but uh
you know some some ideas i mean this is
something i've
felt
several times in my career that that's
such and such an equation such and such
an idea is too beautiful
not to be true uh
and mostly that's been correct
but uh but we're still waiting for
proton decay we're still waiting for
uh low energy super symmetry so
sometimes
things that i thought uh
if there's any justice in the world they
should be happen they should happen
at least they haven't happened yet and
i wanted to uh because in in your
previous book in uh
in a beautiful question you you say you
know i think super symmetry will be
found within the next five years i think
we're about year four and a half so
i want to make a bet i want to make some
bets with you uh frank maybe offline i'm
afraid that's
that's when it seems uh uh
how should i say no more bets are being
taken on that one
all right what about axioms would you
like to make a bet the lhc
is unfortunately the lhc has more or
less
exhausted not quite but
close to i would say having exhausted
its potential for
discovering low energy supersymmetry and
there's no
nothing on the horizon in the near
future that's going to be able to uh
address that question more more closely
right
well i want to um actually on the other
hand we're just
now getting into uh
the sophistication and uh
power of technology to uh
make a serious try at detecting them
yeah yeah so i wanted to offer a bet
with you frank i want to offer a bet
that
uh we buy each other the most the
largest
stuffed mascot of each other's
university
in five years i will give it to you if
axions are
are not discovered and you will give it
to me if axions
are discovered so no matter what we both
win okay
all right do you accept that bet all
right we have it on tape so
i need to know what university is oh uc
san diego
oh that's fine yeah i didn't say tuition
i didn't have to pay tuition for my kids
but all right you get me a giant stuffed
beaver
if it's not detect if it is detected and
i give you a giant stuffed triton
okay i'm going to finish up so that's
that's where you that's where you got
your degree
oh no no i meant oh our current
university
oh our current universe oh okay i all
right that's fine either way it's fine
so
you'll get me a giant
and i'll get you a stuffed triton which
i don't even know what that is but
but anyway i'll get it for you okay
so uh the last thing i want to talk
about just before we
uh we wrap up is uh your work with uh
one of your students
or post i can't pronounce his name he's
of european extraction
and it's about detecting the quantum
nature of gravitational waves
using well okay that's with uh with
malik parikh
who was a student of mine and george
zaharid
who's a student of his i think or a
postdoc with him great
um where is that what is the status of
that and why is it important to
establish
the quantized nature of gravity um uh
for for us to understand the nature of
the fundamentals of reality
well i would have said before we got
involved in
this that uh it's important to show
because people
various people have uh doubted it
and and well it's always it's always
important to
uh to do things that things things you
think
are true actually actually are true in
the world i mean you're
there you can be surprised obviously and
people
uh um
but uh in the course of this
investigation
uh i think i came to realize a week and
we came to realize
that uh gravity the classical treatment
of gravitational radiation
uh really not just in principle but in
reality uh ha is fundamentally
flawed or i mean there's fundamentally
flawed is too strong
fundamentally limited the uh we know
quantum mechanics governs
the world i think most people well most
people who are qualified to pronounce on
the question think so
uh and um uh and we know that there is
such a thing as gravity and we know that
there is such a thing as gravitational
waves and so
it it's it behooves us to
put that phenomenon in the framework of
quantum mechanics and the framework of
our
understanding of the rest of the world
and
that's been done in the literature of
course you have to do that in order to
design
ligo and detectors and think about them
but it's basically been making
assumptions about
the nature of gravitational waves
which reduce them to a classical
phenomenon
we could discuss the technicalities but
basically that's
that's the message and i now think that
that
is severely limited that that's very
misleading
as regards the last moments of black
hole mergers
where the equations become non-linear
and i think the
the gravitational waves during that
period
will not be well described as classical
and so
so originally the the motivation was
kind of uh
dotting the eyes and crossing the t's
and
and uh just showing that it could be
done consistently now i think
there's actually new ground to be broken
wow yeah i
uh i was very curious about that because
i think you know there's this notion
that
gravity has to be quantized and and even
you know part of the
you know theory of everything which
which is what i want to close up talking
about
why are there so many theories of
everything i mean we i i get
two emails a week about a theory of
everything that's because there's a
theory of everything
yeah so i always point out i never get i
never get
emails i should be very i should be more
careful i was gonna say
fools russian where angels fear to tread
okay okay yeah that's less yeah good job
frank that's less controversial than
even by yeah the uh um
but uh well first of all let me let me
clarify
this whole i i really dislike this
phrase
theory of everything because
what people are really talking about is
i think it's better much better
to to a much better uh
version of that is what was what was
what weinberg calls it
a final theory but
first of all so a final theory would be
a an account of the fundamental laws of
nature
which we could argue about exactly what
that encompasses does it encompass
the big bang does it encompass initial
conditions or just though that's just
the laws
of how things people evolve in time
but okay let's leave that question vague
for the moment
if uh but but a description that
so that's that's everywhere we check it
in in experiments is correct and
it uh it describes it doesn't then
there's no phenomenon
that we have observed that's left out of
it
and that it has a kind of logical
closure
it's so beautiful and so difficult to
imagine changing in a consistent way
that it's a fight it becomes a final
theory people lose motivation to try to
do better
this is it as far as fundamental laws of
nature
are concerned because you know it's
battle tested
uh doesn't seem to be ready doesn't seem
to be open to change
and is it seems to be complete so that
would be a final theory of
fundamental physical law it would not
be a theory of everything it would not
be a theory
of uh much of anything really it
wouldn't
be a hit a theory of the history of
sweden or the hist or
or the description of human beings or
their behavior or
you know lots of things that we think of
as part of everything
most people would say everything about
everything
okay but but but a final theory that
that so
and uh we have
a fairly close approximation to that i
would say
in our core theory or standard model
of how the strong weak and
electromagnetic interactions work and
and then how it fits together with
gravity and
works with quantum mechanics and
for purposes of engineering for biology
for chemistry for physics for most of
physics
and most of astrophysics
everything except a few corners of
cosmology
uh those laws have that character that
they are complete they are battle tested
they uh are very difficult to change
and okay so so we have a model and
and we have also ideas about unification
and
vague or ideas about string theory that
might take it further and and
get an even better approximation to a
final theory
so that that's that's
what it means i think somehow that
rambling discussion included the
answer to your question yes i think
maybe you can sign it
yes yeah i i only like though i think
we might achieve a theory a final theory
it would not deserve the name of the
theory of everything and we're not
and in my opinion we're not all that
close we we have achieved it in a
certain practical sense
i don't think we're very close to it in
a philosophical sense i think there are
too many open
issues and loose ends to say that we
certainly i mean you know
hawking's claim that m theory is is
is a final theory which is essentially
what he's claiming is just silly
yeah it's not it's not battle tested
it has not made concrete predictions
about physical phenomena
let alone a complete set of predictions
right so
calling so that's just silly but uh
yes that so but one could imagine
improving what we have now so it
deserves the name of a final theory
uh as i said we do have a final theory
if we're
tracked for many practical purposes but
that does not mean it's a theory of
everything
yeah it's a theory of uh it's a
foundation maybe
for the core understanding the physical
world
but but it does not treat questions of
emergence
or creativity or
or the actual objects that exist around
us
yeah no i think that's beautiful way to
phrase it in a way that
is actually radically not controversial
because i think that's right yeah it's
but it raises a lot of people's hackles
because they're invested
in uh glamorizing their work or
you know which yeah
well i always say you know i get a lot
more emails i've never gotten an email
that says you know boltzmann was wrong
let me show you how
it's always einstein was wrong or will
check is wrong
uh not not but let me just uh close out
that last section before i get to the
final questions by saying i never get
emails about an experiment of everything
and one of the most beautiful things in
a beautiful question
to me was that you you talk about ways
that scientists
in the uh early you know 18th century
like
isaac newton were testing things that
would eventually become part of the core
theory namely
you know the wave-like and particle-like
nature different manifestations of
matter and light
you know for example the the uh the
continuity of the rainbow of the
spectrum
and it reminded me of richard feynman
said you know if an alien
civilization exists and they're
intelligent they should be able to
predict that sometimes we see rainbows
in our in our atmosphere because it's
based on physical laws
it wouldn't it wouldn't necessarily uh
really reveal how we feel
when we see a rainbow or what that
rainbow has been interpreted by
religions around the world
but it made me think that you know we
are we
are the hard part is we not the rainbow
right yes
right and since you know as you pointed
out there's
literally thought to be trillions of
exoplanets it always it always um
galls me a little bit when people say
you know there's there's probably a
trillion planets just like the earth
in the history of the observable
universe and i'm like don't we want to
focus on our own galaxy first you know
before we go back from 13 billion years
to some galaxy that's that distance away
in light yeah anyway
i want to ask you um are there um kind
of
lurking hints at a final theory
at the final evolution of the core
theory you know perhaps in data
that people haven't fully mined when we
look at you know exoplanet data there's
tons of it out there and
we don't have enough time to analyze it
um when we look at
you know avilobe claims that when the
veer ruben observatory comes online
we'll find many of these
omuramura-like objects but that suggests
to me that maybe there's data in the lhc
or in cer or in uh fermilab data or or
in some
very very you know in in laboratory
physics data
like you have shown with anions with
quasi particles
with topological insulators these are
things that could have implications on a
cosmological scale that nobody pays
attention to and nobody writes me about
professor keating
i need uh ten thousand dollars to do an
experiment or to look
and mine the data instead it's let me
come up with this theory of time like
julian barber is doing now he's gonna
come on the show but
why is it that we are not putting as
much attention and looking at
archival data for clues to even some of
these grand
concepts and issues that people are
caring about
well it's
you have to make a concrete proposal i
guess that
uh but i do have some sympathy for the
idea that there may be
ways of analyzing either existing data
or uh practical laboratory experiments
as opposed to uh
you know thought experiments that would
require
thought accelerators that are not likely
to appear
or you know thought black holes that we
don't actually have access to
uh but um there is a thought black hole
frank frank there is a
thought black hole where ideas go to die
it's called twitter
it's called twitter avoid it at all
costs uh
right so but but
yeah so i i do have sympathy for the
idea and
that uh there may be new ways of
analyzing low energy phenomena that
will reveal absolutely fundamental new
insights
well concretely i think the search for
electric dipole moments of elementary
particles is one
of course the search for axions is
carried on through
new kinds of antennas that ultimately
are low energy observations
uh the um the quantum nature of
gravitational waves i think
is a matter of doing delicate processing
of information and maybe setting up
slightly different kinds of in
well maybe not so slightly but different
different antennas that are
that are uh sensitive to entanglement
and sort of
more subtle aspects of radiation fields
so yeah i do think there's a lot of room
for creativity
on the other hand uh
just because the core theory does have
the property of kind of closure
it's very difficult to change its basic
principles without ruining it
and the ways you can change it tend to
be things that
are very challenging to
uh probe experimentally
in a way that's we're the victims of our
own success in a way we've understood
so many kinds of experiments and we
managed to construct this theory that
describes them so well
that it's very hard to improve but maybe
there'll be some
some marvelous surprise yeah
that that i haven't envisaged
now yeah as a uh upcoming guest nema
arkhani hamed
says he uh it's very difficult to break
you know the standard model the core
theory it's very hard to
to disturb it in such a way that you uh
that you you know can make fruitful
predictions that are novel
and and in a way that the core theory
almost has an as an intelligence
a resilience that makes it very hard to
to break
okay i want to wrap up because i know
you've got a million uh
things to do today because it's based
it's based on profound principles so
unless you want to define
some somehow
renounce one of the profound principles
it's very it seems to be very difficult
to change you can but you can augment it
you can add things to it
that also embrace the profound
principles and that
i mean axions are an example of that
yeah and certainly you can derive new
phenomena from it
it's a very you know the people haven't
exhausted its content you know i mean
for heaven's sake
people haven't exhausted the content of
the integers people
just improved from osler's theorem so
so there's a lot you know a lot more to
be drawn out of it but
uh but as to changing it
in in really
basic ways that change its profound
principles that's
that's that's that seems to be really
tough because it works
yeah yeah you break it you bought it
right
i want to thank you for many things for
being an inspiration to
many of us in the world both in the
sciences and outside of the sciences
this book is a is a gateway drug into
the mind
of frank wilcek uh it is uh is a book
full of meaning
and actually you know the laws of
physics describe
what the world is but but i think the
way that you look at it
gives gives a sort of prose but infused
with
with the way a scientist should look at
the world and i found it very beautiful
very moving
almost emotional at some points and and
i want to thank you for being
vulnerable and and and and also
courageous
as i know you always are so thank you
for sharing so much of your time good
luck with the book
thank you and we'll talk to you again
soon when you're when your murder
mystery comes out until next time
until next time i hope this isn't i'm
sure there'll be many next times okay
it's a joy thank you for having me bye
bye
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]